(birds chirping)
- [Daren] There is a
growing movement of people
that are really interested
in recontextualizing
education in our country
with social and emotional
and academic development.
Some of the core elements
that we have here at Valor
are practices that push and
develop all of us to grow.
So Compass Camp is an
evolution of Valor's goal
to really share the work that we're doing.
- At Valor, we focus on a social
emotional learning program
that gives our kids the
necessary character strengths.
(students talking)
We use a model called the Compass.
The Compass has different dimensions:
sharp mind, big heart, noble
purpose, and aligned actions.
Essentially, we are working to develop
all of those dimensions in
our kids and in our adults.
- It starts with the
basic understanding that
we all as humans have a lot of social
and emotional growth to do.
By doing a lot of this
work, we believe that
that's gonna drive them to
incredible academic success.
- Hi, welcome.
- Hi, how are you?
- [Daren] So Compass
Camp is an opportunity
to share the work that we're doing.
- Today I'm in Tennessee
to learn a lot more
about social emotional learning.
The activation and the full
implementation of circles
with adults and kids alike.
- This year, we got some feedback
where students really
felt like they didn't
build relationships with
their teachers as much.
And so we had come here
today to think about
how we could restructure
our advisory program.
- So our Valor Compass is
our primary guiding metaphor.
Today we have leaders from
14 different school networks
across the country and we
are going to introduce them
to our Compass framework, our phase work,
and our circle process with the hope that
we can spread the practice
in a meaningful way.
So we chose the metaphor of the compass
because we really liked the concept that
it's a way of finding
your way in the world.
Our participants get a
brief overview of our model.
In what we call compass discipline.
Working the compass really means
pursuit of excellence in every dimension.
That's something we hold ourselves to,
that's something to hold our kids to.
- Naye, would you tell us a
little bit about your business?
- [Naye] Yeah--
And then, we have them observe
one of our faculty circles.
- I just wanna appreciate
you for the work that you do,
oftentimes behind the scenes.
- So they feel the emotional
vulnerability that's required
and the level of trust and
the types of relationships
that have developed here as
a result of that practice.
In your packet, we actually want you to do
some circle phase work.
(teachers talking)
We then send them home
with the type of phase work
that both our scholars
do and our adults do.
- [Melissa] And so in the packets,
there's reflections and guided questions.
- One example is an exercise
called If You Really Knew Me.
That's a sentence starter and
you're really gonna fill in
as much as you're comfortable sharing
who you are with the circle.
(birds chirping)
In the morning, we tour scholar circles.
So they observe boys
circle and a girls circle.
- I wanna appreciate you because
you show a lot of kindness
and you have a really big heart.
- [Daren] And then they
officially participate
in a circle themselves.
- Just take a few moments to concentrate
and connect with your breath.
- [Daren] Every circle will start
with a mindfulness-based practice
for everybody in the circle to
really focus their attention.
And then it moves into a check-in.
- So I'm gonna ask you to
think of one feeling word.
- Which is a ritualized process.
We're getting everybody's
voice in the room.
- I'm feeling elated.
- I'm feeling grateful today.
- I'm feeling relaxed.
- And then some brave souls
will do some work in the circle
and get to experience it firsthand.
- [Woman] Ezzie, what are you proud of?
- Circle today was a
little bit intimidating.
I'm proud of the type of
work that I do with kids.
I participated in the exercise
called A Thousand Questions.
I'm proud of my two little girls.
No matter how much time it
took you, you are on the spot
and you needed to think
of what you were proud of.
It really made you dig deep,
and it was a cool experience
to think about what I was proud of.
- So we'll move into appreciations next.
This is one of the final parts of circle.
- And then we always
end with appreciations.
- I really appreciate
the work that you do.
- I appreciated your words of gratitude.
- I really appreciate your energy
and the positive vibes
that you gave to me today.
- You're very kind.
- I'm definitely hoping to bring back,
"Here's a structure for
how to do a great circle.
What will it do for our kids overall?"
- After learning about
circles and learning
about the program, I strongly
believe that it will provide
that sense of community
that we're looking for
and allow students to
have a really positive,
deep relationship with
an adult in the school.
- I'm deeply grateful and
humbled that you all came
from all over the country to be here.
I think my biggest hope
is that people recognize
the value of relationships and growth.
This needs to start with us,
the adults in the building.
Then we as a country
actually need to be relating
with each other in different ways
if we want to lead our kids.